[Music]
here's something I want to talk about
love Island no no I'm not in all right
[__] are you in it yeah
it's a good season it seems good I'm
waiting I hate to say it but I'm into it
so did they uh cast uh a light-skinned
black dude named
toe Wesley and then uh Italian guy named
no Italian there's a french guy hmm he's
weird I think and then Adam is there
again well you so you're not in you're
not watching I will be
you will be I 100 will be yeah when are
you gonna start watching
probably this week I just feel the right
way to do it because then you have a
[__] ton of episodes lined up I just
feel that they picked their racial
archetypes
all right we need a ditzy blonde White
English girl yeah we need a tanned
Italian and then we need a mixed race
yeah and then it's just you know
I mean yeah it is it is pretty much they
stick to the script in that in that way
but yeah I kind of like everyone seems
like
in the past season I feel like it's
getting more and more like family
friendly yeah in the sense where they
keep trying to make it about like love
and Purity and it's like people get
coupled up right away right but now it's
like almost like they're encouraging
them to date a little bit more so
there's more fighting
because they're all trying to like date
each other yeah and everyone's like no
I'm staying open
sorry I thought you'd rather they're all
trying to [__] they are trying to [__]
each other but you know they don't they
haven't gotten to that point yet where
they're like still they're still not
admitting that they [__] right
there's people on the show have told us
they're [__] yeah they smash they
smidash yeah smidash like every time
they come back from The Hideaway um
I know the producers are like just tell
them you know tell them that you just
had a nice kiss and you just cuddled
dude they're just like you're in there
just [__] raw dog they're just
sweating
they're just sweating girls just wiping
the we just kissed yeah the eye shadow
or I just the makeup off her eyes she's
like what do you want me to say
just so you had a cuddle they're both
just covered and come yeah
just just say you had a nice cuddle it's
just a snug she just scored it all over
his face yeah yeah he's had a nice
cuddle
there's pubes in their teeth
man come on we just kissed we just had a
nice kiss and had a really nice night
just a little cuddle had a nice night
[Laughter]
yeah it was like a great cuddle
[__] like that yeah you [__] yeah
it was just a nice little this is a nice
cuddle it's a nice cuddle
[Laughter]
turn around open your mouth
let's go to The Hideaway I got down on
air
absolutely shove my fist in her [__]
vagina yeah yeah this is if they were
honest keep going mate I was The
Hideaway last night mate tell us all so
there we are in The Hideaway she's
pulling turds at me ass
flinging them on the wall I said oh my
you're absolute freak I'm in love
next thing I know I'm pulling cute
little tears out of his ass
and I was thinking for a man I'm
expecting like big large chunks of [__]
but it just turns out to be cute little
teds
you know if I want dude I want a [__]
scary like Middle Ages resurrected monk
to just be dropped in the middle of that
yeah like everyone's all hot and this
guy comes in with like a [__] cloak
and a wooden staff yeah
it's treacherous times
like who the [__] is that just so [__]
I'm playing a lot of Diablos that's why
yeah
yeah there was one girl
there was uh there was a 30 year old
wow yeah she got I know she got voted
out right away
ageism I know right how [__] up is
that we should go in there dude 33 and 5
8 and married
the married isn't a problem for these
we're here to chaperone yeah oh [__]
hey hey hey hey yeah no running
just trying to stop a big guy hey hey
hey hey hey listen to me hey all right
eyes down here there she is age 30.
she's from buttermouth
[Music]
damn bro you are horny today what
buttermouth Dang where is she from
buttermouth
Dental nurse yeah called her she's a
dental nurse she stood no chance
yeah she said her age and the guys were
like
wow
what if they said that and then she just
[__] just struck a staff into the
ground and her 30 year old actual so
like her horns and [__] came out yeah
and she was like you dare not laugh yeah
yeah at your elders you have been
playing a lot of Diablo
yeah well a lot a lot of Old Middle Ages
people in there yeah
a dental assistant from Bournemouth
and she was nice too I feel bad for her
it's just like to add to every 22 year
old 30 is just ancient
so I suggest watching it
what what are you laughing at let's
think about this Middle Ages dude still
just working
Laura I find you quite interesting
would you like to come to the Hideaway
with me tonight
no the Scrolls say I cannot
the book of the Damned says I am
forbidden from
what are you what are you saying there
look home
the hatred it consumes here is that a
bombshell
who's Lilith is that a bombshell guys
I've got sex guys I've got a text it's
in a scroll
s oh [__] that'd be the start of a great
[__] stupid comedy movie oh my God
man just six Islanders like he's got a
scrub then they just read it one of them
gets possessed yeah just I've got a
scroll I've got a scratch
oh
[Laughter]
then Laura stands up she's ready
the hatred comes
we're quick we've got no time
somebody has to go in on this show and
[__] around they all just cater to
exactly what the producers say yeah just
go in there [__] around remember cam
remember Chris no oh neither you know
who
foot
um this is like really random but me and
Lena were next to Kaz at oh KSI fight oh
yeah yeah it's really random That Is
Random yeah picture of her
just so I remember
that's it that's the only reason I'm not
I didn't say anything okay oh yes yes
yes yep and she did Josh is that him yes
she died to Josh
yeah I remember
good good times man